imaginez imaginez une ville dont le
règlement assez strictes impose la
hauteur de la pelouse
la couleur des façades des maisons rose
ou bleu les fleurs que l'on peut planter
dans le jardin et même la décoration
intérieure un peu à l'écart de cette
ville on trouve une maison dont les
habitants et les habitantes tente de
respecter le règlement mais à pelouse
est toujours un peu trop haute la
couleur de la façade par exactement de
la bonne nuance et pour cette raison des
voisins se sont autorisés à y jeter
leurs sacs de vidanges les habitants et
les habitants de la maison tente de s'en
débarrasser mais de nouveaux arrivent
chaque jour on plante même une pancarte
interdit de jeter ses sacs de vidanges
ici mais cela ne change quasiment rien
parce que dans la ville on continue de
ne parler de cette maison que pour en
évoquer le jardin abîmé dans cette ville
où j'ai grandi de 0 à 12 ans j'ai lu où
on m'a lu des milliers de livres
quant à 12 ans je suis tombé en amour
avec une fille je n'avais encore jamais
lu un seul livre ou une fille était
amoureuse d'une fille mes camarades de
classe et mes amis non plus on savait
que ça existait on savait même comment
ça s'appelait pour les
garçons fif
si j'avais grandi au québec
quand tu es jeune tu le sais qu'il
existe une maison un peu à l'écart
ça se peut même que tes copains et toi
soyez aller y jeter quelques sacs de
vidanges mais t'as pas envie d'y habiter
t'as pas envie d'être la la
bouche
le fiff la des mots qui sont
prononcés quotidiennement dans nos
écoles des milliers de fois par jour et
qui trace une ligne entre celles et ceux
qui respectent les règles et les autres
des gays des lesbiennes des bisexuels ça
dérange
t'es un gars qui aime le rose ou la
danse ça dérange
tu es une fille qui aime la mécanique ou
le hockey
malgré les avancées ça dérange toujours
vous allez me dire c'est vrai qu'il faut
que ça change mais ça ne concerne pas
grand monde presque 40% des élèves du
secondaire sont victimes d'homophobie
c'est ce que montre une étude récente
dirigé par lyne chamberland
la titulaire de la chaire de recherche
sur l'homophobie de l'uqam et c'est sans
compter les autres il y a les jeunes que
l'on insulte pas mais qu'ils reçoivent
par ricochet les effets de ces insultes
quotidiennes
tu as un frère une soeur des parents
homosexuels un ou une ami bisexuels ça
t'affecte mais ça affecte encore une
dernière catégorie de personnes toutes
celles et tous ceux qui s'empêchent de
pratiquer des activités ou même
d'exprimer des émotions
le règlement impose la décoration
intérieure de peur d'être rangé dans la
mauvaise catégorie
bref l'homophobie touche tout le monde
c'est toute la ville qui subissez
règlement qui empêche de s'épanouir
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait on interdit
de jeter les sacs de vidanges c'est vrai
que c'est important dans ces sacs
il ya des mots qui coupent et qui laisse
de profondes cicatrices mais si on
allait plus loin et si ensemble on ne
lui était plus seulement entre les
fruits empoisonnés de l'homophobie mais
aussi contre serre
sin racines qui porte un hétéro
normativité qu'est ce que c'est que ce
mot barbare pour le dire le plus
simplement possible
c'est l'idée que quand on est on est
soit un garçon soit une fille et de
cette première identification
découlerait naturellement des façon de
s'habiller différente des capacités
différent des intérêts différents des
comportements différents et même des
façons de penser et des émotions
différentes ce qui mène désolé pour les
gars sont sur cette image ce qui mène à
des rôles dans la famille et dans la
société différent donc pour qu'un couple
puis une famille soit équilibrée elle
doit être composée de deux entités
complémentaires
un homme et une femme un papa et maman
et sète hérault normativité supporter
peu ce qui la remet en question ce qui
conduit à l'invisibilisation des
orientations sexuelles
autre que l'hétérosexualité ou des
comportements non conformes aux
stéréotypes de la masculinité et de la
féminité mais aussi à du dénigrement
voire à de la violence psychologique ou
physique
alors imaginez imaginer que toute la
ville s'allie aux habitants et aux
habitantes de la maison que toute la
ville prenne un pinceau pour rependre
les vieux murs roses et bleues de
couleurs éclatantes que toute la ville
plantes dans les jardins des fleurs du
monde entier que la maison finalement
pas si éloigné soit célébré comme une
richesse comme une chance d'embellir
toute la ville comme dans ces écoles où
d'après plusieurs études menées par
elizabeth saewyc chercheuse en santé de
la jeunesse de l'université de colombie
britannique comme dans ces écoles où la
présence
d'un comité d'alliés de la diversité
sexuelle et de genre diminue de moitié
le taux d'idéation suicidaire de tous
les garçons et diminue drastiquement la
consommation d'alcool et de drogues de
tout léger alors imagine imaginer qu
existe une place tous ses alliés
pourraient se retrouver échanger sur le
pourquoi et le comment retrouver des
informations des ressources des pistes
d'actions concrètes
cette place existe le bureau
d'architectes qui m'ont a confié la
réalisation se rend depuis 18 ans dans
les écoles pour démystifier
l'homosexualité et la bisexualité pour
faire tomber des murs et bâtir des ponts
alors avec nos propres alliés avec des
organismes partenaires avec des
chercheurs des chercheuses des
professionnels de terrain des bénévoles
de développeurs au talent tentaculaire
nous avons bâti sur le web une place des
alliés une place où la petite fille de
12 ans et qu'elle peut aimer sens caché
une place où je l'espère on se
retrouvera pour que la ville notre ville
se pare de couleurs chatoyantes dont la
variété fera briller toutes les facettes
de nos enfants